you
Schekman it's an honor to meet to anchor
regulations on the award of your mind I
heard that you will james rothman use to
call each other every year the day after
the another yes we have we've we've
developed different terms to express
what has happened or not happened that
Sunday night so what was this cool like
this was very different this was much
earlier in the morning I called him
before the press conference here in
Stockholm and we just compared notes and
the you know got ready for the challenge
ahead yeah I heard that too thanks your
high school biology yes yes he was so
how working this case well he was he was
instrumental he he first introduced
himself to me when I even before I
started high school I was my annual
performance of a science fair project
he came up to me he said I'm going to be
your biology teacher next year so we'll
have more to discuss them and he was
throughout my high school years very
encouraging every year I did a science
fair project they became more and more
elaborate and so we've kept in touch
over the years including curiously this
year he out of the blue sent me an email
and said he'd looked me up on google and
was impressed with what i done and said
this was before the this was before the
award for months ago and i correspond
with him i sent him a video some other
things I've done and now in the morning
of October seventh after I you know
after the press conference he sent me an
email and congratulate gradually me said
how wonderful of one's word that he was
still alive
he told me he said he said that you've
now replaced Tiger Woods is the most
famous graduate of our high school he
was being kind actually your student
seem to love you just as much as you
love him I even heard this song that's
dedicated to you really but I was
wondering um you seem to be driven by an
insatiable curiosity from an early age
is it true but you call the police and
your parents with saving up for us
Marcus yeah well I actually bicycle to
the police station because they were
borrowing my money from an envelope that
I was using to accumulate money to buy
up by a microscope and up my father came
over to police station and he had some
words with the chief of police and then
came out and took me to a pawn shop that
afternoon and i bought my microscope for
a hundred dollars and i donated that
microscope not at the nobel museum oh
cuz he's didn't have it I I had it yes I
kept it for decades and the first I
wasn't using it anymore I have better
microscopes in my laboratory so I
thought when I was asked to think of
something to do Nate here this is the
perfect gift yes otherwise doing nothing
so your father must have forgiven you
buy it yes if is it he first he was a
little disappointed that I didn't go to
medical school but he's forgiven me I
was wondering because I'm for heard
scientists rave about this elegant
experiment to be using just bakeries and
floor polish but did you know by then
that this seemingly simple experiment
could leave
send me the first experiments that
yielded results that I thought would
lead us over a long path came before
this experiment that you referred to
using floor polisher when we just picked
two colonies randomly and looked for
mutants that block secretion locked
export and we found one and it conformed
all the all the conditions that we had
imposed through for a good mutant but
the most dramatic thing really one of
the most dramatic results I ever had in
my career was when my student Peter
Novick had a thin section and looked at
the slice through this mutant cell using
the electron microscope and he called me
down excitedly to the gem room from my
office and there was a cell just
chock-full of us don't know what had
seen anything like like this before that
was a dramatic moment and I knew from
that moment on that made many good
things to do this was the start of this
yes sir thank you so much for talking to
us and please enjoy I will